[Musica]
la prima visionate fantasia che vi
racconto una brevissima storia che
comunque lascia spazio
avete già sentito tantissime storie mi è
capitato nella vita di suonare con
tantissimi musicisti bravissimi meno
bravi e tutte le volte è una sfida non
conoscere nuovi musicisti avere a che
fare con persone diverse e mi è capitato
una volta di fare una residenza a
firenze per un festival di musica
africana con musicisti che che sia
africani che europei in questa residenza
dove praticamente stavamo un periodo per
preparare questo festival
succedeva che che sì sì strutturavano
dei piccoli set con con formazioni di
piccole no anche due o tre dove dove poi
venivano tutti esposti nel festival e
nel festival poi avremmo suonato anche
tutti insieme mi è capitato di suonare
con questo chitarrista tuareg che agì
ahmed che per la prima volta mi sono
trovato veramente in difficoltà perché
non riuscivo a entrare a comunicare con
questa persona lui suonava i suoi pezzi
e io non riuscivo toccava la chitarra e
mi rendevo conto che mi risultava tutto
complesso perché lui aveva un modo di
portare il tempo molto molto strano io
avevo difficoltà per la prima volta mi
sono sentito in imbarazzo davanti a un
chitarrista che mi rendevo conto anche
non essere più bravo di me
ma proprio fare un'altra roba dopo un po
che provavamo ci siamo fermati e abbiamo
iniziato a parlare a conoscerci un po
meglio gli ho chiesto io ho fatto una
domanda già detto ma tu quanti anni hai
e lui mi ha risposto non lo so
quindi praticamente lui non sa il giorno
in cui è nato
questa cosa praticamente mi ha
letteralmente sconvolto perché ho
cominciato a pensare ma se io non avessi
il giorno di nas
come come come sarebbe la mia vita noi
siamo abituati a scandire tutto con con
dalla data di nascita
facciamo il compleanno a 6 anni andiamo
a scuola 18 anni siamo maturi ma chi lo
dice che siamo motori a di citarmi
magari lo siamo a 16 o aventi non si
sanno invece noi abbiamo tutte queste
scadenze che ci che ci che ci segnalano
ogni volta qualcosa il tempo scandito
molto precisamente e questa cosa alla
fine si riflette anche per suonare
perché noi suoniamo tutto molto molto
precisi mentre questo chitarrista tuareg
e ho capito che avesse una va molto più
libero di me perché non è il punto di
partenza la data di nascita non ce l'ha
e quindi nel deserto completo c'è ed è
assolutamente libero quindi pensavo mi
farò sentire un pezzo di questo ragazzo
di quest'oasi a mezzo grazie
[Musica]
all
no
[Musica]
eccola